Warcraft 3 kiwami Blizzcon 2018 first
day is done we were at the opening
ceremony which was it was pretty big it
was hoppin there's like it was tough to
get into but uh at least we got hands-on
with a lot of the new stuff that
Blizzard was showing off so the biggest
stuff was diablo mortal which is the
mobile game and we also saw warfare 3
reforged yeah Warcraft or even forged a
new hearthstone expansion was a rosca
cons grumble overwatch was probably
always steals the show at least for me
you know so we got a new character a new
cinematic involving the creep new
character ash she looks great
yes well I like what stood out to you
like what what do you care about most
after the day is done
definitely Diablo I came in like
expecting something I didn't know quite
what they were about to reveal I sort of
reconcile with myself that you know we
weren't gonna see table for like it was
gonna happen but it was interesting
seeing a mobile basically take on Diablo
and I had some initial reservations but
I actually got a chance to play it
myself and I also interviewed the
developers and I came away pretty
impressed with how it transitioned over
to mobile how does it compare in terms
of like how the pacing works is it as
fluid as Diablo 3 or like where does it
stand in it
as compared to Diablo I definitely feel
like it's very much familiar with like
the console edition like you know
control wise and all that but it feels a
bit faster actually Oh
which makes sense because it's newer
you're taking this on the go and you
need to have sort of those flight size
like you know levels to actually play
through but um just the pacing of it it
just felt really fluid and
I'm really impressed with just how one
it looked pretty solid like it ran
pretty smoothly for the most part and it
played great and I'm just impressed they
sort of managed to pack that in yeah you
know the mobile like a mobile device um
there's gonna be six characters like
once the game comes out but we were only
able to play as The Wizard monk and
barbarian they played great yeah I know
some people were kind of I guess more or
less disappointed that they were quite
angry actually yeah which I think is
that within itself is disappointing yeah
you know people put their put so much
work into a game so I think you know it
might not be exactly what everyone was
wishing for but I think there's
something there and I'm like seeing it
in action and hearing about your
experience you know it's like there's
something there and so yeah hopeful for
that I think when sort of the anger and
maybe just disappointment sort of
dissipates you know people will actually
sort of give the game a fair shake it'll
come away surprised because what is that
it works quite well actually I think the
biggest thing for me was ash new
character for overwatch that's probably
the the Blizzard property that I am most
attached to at this point it's always a
big deal when they revealing it yeah and
it's also a big deal so I got actually
gotten hands-on with her and she's my
time in terms of like the character like
in her abilities because she has like
this semi-auto Winchester but if you aim
down sights
it makes her shots slower but does more
damage and it makes them more precise so
it's kind of like this this middle
ground between a Widowmaker and maybe
like soldiers 76 in a way because like I
can land those precise shots but I don't
have to subject myself to using a sniper
right yeah and it seemed like she's sort
of like the anti McCree in a way she's
got range and she actually she's also a
cowboy or so she's Chuck's dynamite yeah
Chuck's the dynamite and the cool thing
about that is like it has a like area
effect damage of course but you can
throw it into a crowd and then shoot the
dynamite itself to ignite it and then it
also inflicts burn damage so there's uh
there's some dynamics going on that I
think are really interesting she has
like this sound it's kind of like
kinetic gun that's dead depending on
which direction
you shoot it in can like propel you
backwards it can propel you forward or
the direction you want to go it's a
basically it's like concussive so if you
want to like push enemies away you can
use it in that sense or if you want to
like get up over a Ledge to kind of
flank enemies gives us some aiming
towards the ground and you get over that
and which I was doing quite a bit when I
was actually playing so it's you can do
some clever things with her and now the
last thing I'll say about her is the bob
bob kind of stole the show and that's
cinematic her a her little or big robot
friend that's our ultimate when Ashe
calls him in he hits the ground rushes
forward and becomes a turret so it's
just like shooting fools left and right
and if you're not prepared for that if
you your team isn't like focused on
controlling Bob when he gets summoned
into the into the map I can wreck your
whole team because that I did that and I
was like oh man and the same thing
happened to me to another my opponent
called Bob and just wiped us all out
while we're on the pail oh and I was
like wasn't paying attention to but
overall I really like what she brings to
the table yeah another thing I got to
see was a Warcraft 3 report oh yeah that
was a big deal because you know for one
war World of Warcraft has sort of become
like Warcraft like the staple Warcraft
universe yeah it was interesting when we
were leaving the opening ceremony after
it ended I overheard some people talking
with one of their kids and the kid was
like you know so what was Warcraft 3
again and the parents are trying to
explain to this kid like hey this is
what Warcraft used to be look youngin I
can't really you know bolt the kid about
it because like you know for one wall
the Warcraft has been around for 14
years yes and it's a massive game like
there's so much to a place you can
totally immerse yourself in the world
the lore and all the characters in that
so I kind of forget that it was an RTS
to be good yeah so yeah that was that
was a big surprise to that Warcraft 3
was the thing that they were gonna
and I play a little bit of warcraft 3
you know when I was a lot younger so I'm
definitely gonna dive back into that
universe in the RTS sense yeah and it's
really interesting because you wouldn't
really think that real time strategies
would make a big splash in a way but I
feel like Blizzard is trying pretty hard
to kind of not just bank on that
nostalgia but maybe find a resurgence of
real time strategy because last year
they brought out Starcraft remastered
they're still working on Starcraft 2
yeah we saw a bit of that at the opening
ceremony yeah they're doing some things
with Starcraft 2 but bring it in
Warcraft 3 reign of chaos and Frozen
Throne 4 Warcraft 3 kiwami I would say
yeah it's yeah it's it's nice to see
that RTS is are kind of they still have
a state yeah in PC games pretty cool
yeah they're actually keeping the game
as it was like you know we're from the
original yeah all the animations are the
same so the the gameplay itself will
still be consistent with what it was
yeah it's very much the same treatment
they gave to Starcraft reactors where
they're not touching balancing they're
not touching kind of like the spirit of
the game everything's gonna function as
you remembered from Warcraft 3 it just
gonna be like better he's gonna look a
whole lot better and even though those
cinematics are also getting getting
spruced up but speaking of Warcraft I
think that you can't get away from
Blizzcon this year without talking about
world of warcraft classic I was actually
talking to the team that is heading up
the wild classic project and they said
it's gonna be vanilla Wow but it's gonna
be one of the later patches that came
along in about 2005 so this is free
Burning Crusade yes pretty Burning
Crusade and yeah they don't really have
any plans like incorporate expansions
it's intended to preserve the original
Warcraft experience because it's an MMO
it's an online game so as soon as they
patch it or booth new things get
implements it's to that the original
it's kind of gone you can't really play
that it's a treat for those who have
nostalgia for OG world of warcraft but
it's also this has been around for 14
years so those who have jumped in in the
middle of its lifecycle can look back
and be like what was it like back then
do I want to play it
for me it's it's a novelty yeah it's a
novelty in that there are some people
who are gonna find a lot of enjoyment
out of it but for me I was kinda like oh
this is I remember summer 2005 playing
with my homies on summer break and
that's the that's as much enjoyment I'll
get out of it but it's really nice that
they are doing that one thing you've got
to say about Blizzcon is that the fans
are dedicated to see like cosplayers and
people getting like really hyped when
there's announcements and like when jeff
Kaplan's on stage I was like yo as Jeff
Kaplan and they like the whole thing
with Mike Moore I'm passing the torch in
the opening ceremony it's kind of a it's
a testament to how long Blizzard has
lasted and the impact they have in games
in general but also how much people care
about these games so to see it in action
is uh it's pretty dope I like it a lot
it's a long reflection you know
basically and my own you know from my
own and my attachment to gaming is all
like I totally see how Blizzard games
have had a firm place and like you know
my sort of passion for gaming right yeah
so I don't man it'd be a lot more to do
a lot more bliss cons in the future yeah
but uh yeah blitz con 2018 that was in
anything huge but you know there's still
still a lot to celebrate you know and
enjoy out here
[Music]
you